7.861 Rückführungen im ersten Halbjahr
in der vergangenen Woche nur in einer
Woche sind auf Lampedusa 10.000 Menschen
deswegen sage ich ja die
migrationsabkommen sind ganz
entscheidend weil wir eben nur drei
funktionieren die werden auch nicht
funktionieren
Herr Seehofer hat ja wie gesagt
Rückführungsabkommen versucht zu
verhandeln aber ohne jedes wir reden
jetzt über heute wir sagen wir brauchen
Zuwanderung wir wollen legale
Zuwanderungswege ermöglichen für
Menschen die die Qualifikation
mitbringen die wir brauchen
nein nein das gehört zusammen das gehört
zusammen soll in den migrationsabkommen
genau so verhandelt werden
[Musik]